[Applause]
[Music]
okay so first off i'll do the not funny
like there's a million jokes we can
throw in there now let's just do the
joke part first and that'll be all right
let's just show the trump version one
more time
okay all right so we can do all the
funny versions of this but i really want
you to think about how close we got to
today being very different than
yesterday uh that's a roughly eight how
old is he 79 78 something i think he's
79 right that's a 79 year old man
falling off a bike when a 79 year old
man falls off a bike usually that's the
last time they get on a bike
if they're lucky because you could very
easily break a hip break something else
this is a guy who's had a series i think
he's had a couple of brain aneurysms
like we all know about the general state
of his mental health and all that you
know physically in terms of his body he
actually for a 79 year old looks like
he's in decent enough shape uh but the
point is that if he falls one inch one
way or one inch the other way uh that's
the broken hip right and we know what
happens when old people break their hip
i'm not being glib or funny about it or
whatever i would like not like to break
my hip as a matter of fact i'm doing two
times a week now i'm going to physical
therapy because i got something going on
with my shoulders so this is not to mock
anyone's physical abilities but the
point is
that the guy is 79 years old and had he
fallen slightly differently
do you know what would be happening
right now
do you know
do you want to sit with it for just a
minute i'm freaking people out right now
you guys are freaking out i can tell
basically
kamala harris would be in charge
okay
if that doesn't freak you out if that
isn't the scariest freaking thing you've
ever heard then i don't know what is
okay uh so we need to talk about these
things right uh he is not well and we
are that close we are we were one you
know there was a little pebble that he
would have fallen a little bit
differently one way or another broken
hip he's in the hospital
and there we go
but
the machine the machine still likes him
now remember the machine when donald
trump
drank water with two hands remember they
said he couldn't hold a glass of water
donald trump one day in the rain he
walked down a ramp slowly and they said
he was going to fall and he can't
balance the series of reasons that we
impeached him and they said things were
wrong with him and all of those things
but here was the headline in the
atlantic yesterday after biden fell
the heroism of biden's bike fall the
president gracefully illustrated an
important lesson for all americans when
we fall we must get back up we had a
whole bunch of headlines that
were the complete reverse when trump
walked down the ramp slowly and i was
like ah we don't have to show them
because everyone gets it that these same
organizations that they run cover when
it's democrats they run complete offense
when it's republicans